hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his sermon number eight Joseph Butler
is going to make a distinction between
two different we could call them kinds
or modalities of anger and he says in
terms of resentment which is he's using
synonymously there it is of two kinds
Hasty and sudden or settled and
deliberate and he tells us the former
Hasty or sudden is called anger and
often passion which through a general
word is frequently appropriated and
confined to the particular feeling
sudden anger as distinct from deliberate
resentment malice and revenge and it
tells us that in all of these words
every one of them is usually implied
somewhat vicious somewhat unreasonable
as to the occasion of the passion or in
moderate as to the degree or duration of
it and then he says but that the natural
passion itself is indifferent friend
Saint Paul is asserted in that priest
that be angry and sin not and a lot of
our sudden anger is going to be fairly
easy to to mold into that injunction
right and so when he talks about sudden
or Hasty anger he tells us at the very
beginning sudden anger on certain
occasions so not all the time but much
of the time is mere Instinct and he
gives us the example of the disposition
to close our eyes in his rather fancy
words upon the apprehension of somewhat
falling into them right it doesn't imply
reason so we have these these you could
call them reflexes or stimulus response
mechanisms within our our bodies so you
know there's all sorts of things that we
might be susceptible in those cases
somebody pinches us we don't like it we
turn around oh what are you doing there
you know animals you pull the dog's tail
bad idea right because dogs don't like
that cats don't either
um you know there's often a way children
get get a lesson about doing that sort
of thing
um children he talks about infants in
here but also about grown people we have
all sorts of things like that some of us
don't like feeling wet you know if it's
a hot you know humid day and we're
sweaty or something like that that can
make us irritable some of us get upset
when uh you know we'd hear a loud sound
or somebody bumps into us or we're stuck
funneling into a line with a crowd and
we have bodies jostling against us so
these are are things as he says that are
occasioned by mere sensation and feeling
things happen to our bodies or
threatened to happen to our bodies and
we respond bond with this sudden or
Hasty anger and you can substitute other
things irritability being on edge but
there's there's a response that is
characteristic of anger and kind of
looks like the anger that we feel that
he calls settled or deliberate anger
when when there's something more going
on here
and it's occasioned by um opposition by
as he says sudden hurt or violence you
know it could be the opposition could be
something like you're carrying your
groceries out in a bag and suddenly the
bag rips at the bottom and your glass
jars fall to the ground and break and
you're like oh damn it right you're
angry about that sort of thing so
opposition could cover a very wide range
it could be being stuck in traffic it
could be
um you know the wind blowing on you in a
way that you don't like sudden hurts to
our body
um things that suddenly arise that make
us feel bad it doesn't have to be
necessarily uh just an ache or a pain it
could be getting burned it could be
getting
too cold it could be all sorts of things
that we don't like violence people can
you know like jump at us and then we get
angry at them or something along those
lines all sorts of of possibilities here
and he says that these sorts of things
for human beings
actually not just for human beings for
Animals as well naturally excite this
passion of sudden anger now it's
different than deliberate anger in one
key way besides being sudden or Hasty
and not lasting that long
as he says it doesn't involve the
thought of demerit or fault when it's a
mere Instinct thing right
so we're just responding we're not
attributing bad motives to the other
person we're not saying that they're a
bad person we're not we're not
projecting those sorts of things out
there and this is very interesting
because this means that at least in some
cases of anger at least according to
Joseph Butler
we don't have to have something that is
often
viewed as a component of anger which is
a bad motivation on the part of the
other person doing something to us that
we don't deserve right and doing it
perhaps deliberately
so you know he says that this momentary
anger is frequently raised not only
without any real but without any
apparent reason that is without any
appearance of injury as distinct from
hurt or pain he says I cannot I suppose
be thought that this passion in infants
in the lower species of animals and
which is often seen in men towards them
right so this this often does happen
sometimes however it does involve reason
here are the distinction between
deliberate anger and or settled anger
and Hasty or sudden anger would not be
that one doesn't have injury or the
attribution of injury and the other does
it would really just be about the
duration right we get angry quickly but
we don't remain angry all that long
and so
you know sometimes reason
as he tells us suggests to us that the
other person is in fact injuring us or
showing us contempt in which case we can
we can get angry at them you know we
might think about Aristotle's
um
uh example in the rhetoric uh forgetting
somebody's name now if if somebody
forgets your name at say uh a social
occasion
and you get angry with them and you're
going to wait for your revenge later on
that's not sudden anger right that is
deliberate or settled anger but if they
forget your name and you actually have
to tell it to them and you're
momentarily put out by that upset by it
well that's sudden anger it's gonna
disappear fairly quickly
now Butler thinks that all anger
actually has some sort of purpose or
function and that that's why we have it
as a capacity
within ourselves
so what is the purpose as he says of the
liability to this passion liability
means our susceptibility our
vulnerability to this passion why is it
that we and other animals are made in
such a way as to have this
being able to be you know irritable
being able to respond in an angry way
what what good does it actually do so he
says well that it might that the person
might be better qualified to prevent and
likewise or perhaps chiefly to resist
and defeat so there's three different
things there prevent resist defeat what
sudden Force violence and opposition the
various same things that occasion it
right so we
Things Push at us they might hurt us
they might do things that not good for
us and we we push back sort of
instinctively right that is this this
anger response and it's there as a part
of our nature in order to do that right
I mean we we have other parts of our
nature we could talk about you know uh
when we're faced with a threat we can
fight or take flight sometimes we also
freeze
um you know the fight response that's
the anger the flight response that's
perhaps fear or something like that and
so he tells us that it stands in our
nature for the purpose of self-defense
that is the actual term that he he uses
there a little bit later uh he's going
to say that sudden anger is raised by
and was chiefly intended to prevent
remedy mere harm distinct from injury
but it can also be raised by injury as
well right so it helps us to defend
ourselves and He suggests that in some
parts of the world where there is not a
settled government an uncultivated part
of the world this may be in fact very
important to have like if you're in you
know Nature by itself you need to be
able to respond to threats in your
environment and if you're in with a
bunch of other people who are otherwise
going to maybe take advantage of you or
do things that you don't like you have
to be able to push back against them so
this is quite important but he says it's
not for the administration of justice
that is not the point of it now a little
bit later
he's going to say that this could
accidentally and we'll talk about that
word what it means in its scope serve to
prevent or remedy harm or injury right
so
um it's it's only helping us out you
could say
we you know we would say by accidents
here but that means contingently it's
that's not its purpose that's the
purpose actually of settled anger or
deliberate anger but this can this can
help out with that if somebody is
bumping into us because they're a jerk
and they want to like abuse us or you
know put us bully us into a one down
position versus them right getting angry
at them and pushing back that could
actually prevent or remedy the harm or
injury but that is not the fundamental
purpose of this sudden or Hasty anger
which uh you know is is just there as he
says for self-defense the defense of us
as the people that we are without
worrying about moral motivations or
issues of Justice